Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, die 2. Männer Bundesliga. Sie hat ihren letzten Spieltag hinter sich. Für 17, nein für 16 der 18 Mannschaften ist die Saison vorbei. Darüber wollen wir sprechen jetzt hier in Rasenfunk Kurzpass 204. Hallo, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Ihr seid wahrscheinlich auch noch elektrisiert von diesem Saison Finale in der 2. Männer Bundesliga. So geht es uns auch. Und deshalb wollen wir das jetzt aufarbeiten. In der Runde der emotional direkt Beteiligten. Deswegen begrüße ich bei mir und frage sie, ob sie ihre Stimme wiedergefunden hat. Sina vom Weserfunk, die Ed, Sina, Sophie, auf Twitter. Hallo, Sina.
Und nein, sie ist noch sehr verschollen. Ich hoffe, ich finde sie im Laufe des Tages wieder.
Aber man hört die Endorphine quasi durch diese raue Stimme. Das ist doch auch schön. Geht es dir? Ich nehme an, es geht dir gut.
Fantastisch. Also es ist ja alles super gelaufen. Ich war mega, mega nervös, weil das Finale der Bundesliga am Tag davor ja schon so in den letzten paar Sekunden gefühlt sich einmal alles gedreht hat. Und davor hatte man natürlich selber auch Angst. Und deswegen war die Erleichterung sehr, sehr groß und die Freude dann umso größer.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Und wenn es um ein Saisonfinale geht, das spannend ist und um Spannung, die vielleicht sich auch mehrmals am Tag gedreht hat und mehrmals im Verlauf des Spiels, dann kann ich auch Tanja Hufschmidt sehr herzlich sich hier begrüßen vom HSV-Talk von Friff bei twitter.de, fschmid77. Hallo Tanja, ich vermute, dir ging das ähnlich mit der Achterbahn der Gefühle und der Aufregung.
Moin. Also, ja, es war klassisch HSV eigentlich. Das ist so dieses Irrationale. Eigentlich glaubt man an seine Mannschaft, aber man ist trotzdem so wahnsinnig...
Man ist immer auf der Hut, weil sie einem schon so oft wehgetan hat, oder?
Ja, also eigentlich in dieser Saison, man hat so ein bisschen Vertrauen in diese Mannschaft gewonnen, aber ja, man ist halt gebranntes Kind, das hilft nichts.
Naja, es hat ja immerhin für die Relegation gereicht und das bedeutet aber auch, dass der Dritte hier in der Runde, Matthias Kneifl, von hoch und weit, dem Kickshoe-Block und als Ad-Kickshoe-Block ist er auch auf Twitter. Ihr kennt ihn hoffentlich schon, ist ein alter Freund des Rasenfunkes. Matthias, bei dir Stimmung gedrückt, ernüchtert, wo bewegt es sich bei dir?
Ich würde sagen, die Stimmung ist gefasst. Wir hatten leider den Matchball, nicht den Matchball, aber eine gute Chance am vorletzten Spieltag in Düsseldorf, Freitagabend, so den Druck hochzuhalten auf die Konkurrenzen. Wir haben es da leider liegen lassen, insofern hatten wir es nicht mehr in der eigenen Hand. Und damit bin ich gestern eigentlich ganz locker in das Spiel gegangen. Wir konnten ja nichts mehr verlieren, das hatten wir leider jetzt im Nachhinein auch in Düsseldorf. Insofern habe ich dann auch mitgekriegt, dass Hamburg mal zwischenzeitlich zurückliegt und dass ich da was entspinnen könnte. Aber ich war da dann nicht mehr so gefixt. Also für mich hat sich das dann so tatsächlich am Ende dargestellt, wie ich es erwartet hatte.
Ehrlich, warst du nicht nach dem… Also die Führung von Darmstadt, die kam ja sehr schnell jetzt im Spiel gegen Paderborn, das lief alles schön nach Plan. Und auch das 1 zu 0 von Hansa Rostock im Parallelspiel hat bei dir keine Dinge ausgelöst?
Na ja, ich dachte, klar, HSV ist immer gut für Überraschungen, aber das war halt auch noch lange zu spielen. Und ich denke, da HSV hat sich jetzt zuletzt schon sehr stabil erwiesen, dass man da jetzt nicht nervös werden musste oder euphorisiert, weil dann wäre die Gefahr, enttäuscht zu werden, ja noch größer. Insofern habe ich das natürlich mitgekriegt, aber dann hat der HSV ja auch gleich nach der Pause den Ausgleich erzielt. Und dann schien es ja doch in die richtigen Bahnen für den HSV zu gehen. Insofern, ich war tatsächlich nicht so angefixt, also weil ich in Düsseldorf auch dabei war und habe da gesehen, wie leider es dahin ging und das war schlimmer als gestern, definitiv.
Tanja, wie war es für dich 0 zu 1 Aussicht des HSV gegen Hansel Rostock?
Also die erste Halbzeit war wirklich schlimm, weil das war wieder so ein Spiel, wo wir nicht so richtig reingekommen sind. Und dann weiß man auch, das kann dann auch mal in einem Unentschieden enden und das hätte in dem Augenblick nicht mehr gereicht, weil Darmstadt dann plötzlich zur Halbzeit schon 3-0 führte. Also insofern wussten wir natürlich, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie vernünftig aus der Pause kommen und endlich auch mal selber Torchancen generieren und vernünftig in die Zweikämpfe kommen. Und das haben sie dann auch glücklicherweise geschafft. Aber so die erste Halbzeit, das war schon...
Kannst du denn erklären, warum das so war? Hatte das mit dem Forschen-Anlaufen von Rostock zu tun, dass die eben, obwohl die Saison für sie tabellarisch gesehen schon beendet war, sehr viel Druck gemacht haben auf den HSV?
Ja, also zum einen hat Rostock das wirklich für sich gut gemacht. Und zum anderen war das auch so ein bisschen so eine HSV-Krankheit in dieser Saison, dass sie die erste Halbzeit hin und wieder mal etwas verpennt haben und gerade so die ersten Minuten sich da gerne irgendwelche Gegentore gefangen haben, die so völlig vermeidbar wären und dann einfach den Rest der Zeit gegen anrennen. Und mal klappt es dann, dass sie das noch wieder gut machen konnten, aber häufig genug dann zum Beispiel in Kiel oder auch gegen Paderborn hat es dann halt nicht hingehauen. Und deswegen wird man dann doch schon ein bisschen nervöser, als man es eh schon ist.
Und dann Robert Glatzel mit dem Ausgleich in der 50. Minute. Ein bemerkenswerter Kopfball. Würde mich interessieren, ob er den so setzen wollte oder ob er einfach nur gedacht hat, ich versuche jetzt mein Gesicht letztlich gegen den Ball zu stellen und dann gucken wir mal, was passiert. Was passierte, war, dass der Ball aufspringt an die Unterkarte der Latte und von dort ins Tor. Das war der Ausgleich und das schien so ein bisschen der Wendepunkt zu sein, weil dann war es in Anführungszeichen nur noch ein Tor und vor allem war der HSV im Spiel. Dennoch hat es ja noch eine Weile gedauert, 75. Minute, dann Sebastian Schonlau. Beides nach Flanken die Tore. Wie ist die zweite Hälfte für den HSV gelaufen? Hat sich da spielerisch was verändert oder ist es so eine Partie, wo man sagen muss, gut, das war jetzt vor allem psychologisch, was da geschehen ist auf dem Feld?
Also eigentlich dachte ich zur Halbzeit, dass Tim Walter dann eventuell auf ein 4-4-2 umstellen würde, weil hilft ja nichts, wir müssen irgendwie gewinnen. Hat er aber nicht. Aber er hat, ich glaube, in der Kabine war es wohl ein bisschen lauter. Das hörte man auch nach dem Spiel bei den Aussagen von Sebastian Schonlaus ein bisschen raus, dass Tim Walter wohl nicht ganz zufrieden war. Und dann, das war einfach von der Mannschaftsleistung her eine absolute Steigerung zur ersten Hälfte. Sie waren plötzlich viel präsenter, auch in den Zweikämpfen viel aggressiver gegen den Ball. Und dann spielen sie halt auch ihre individuelle Klasse in dem Augenblick aus. Also die Flanke vor dem 1-1 kam von Mario Vuskovic und zwar punktgenau wirklich dann auf Glatze von dem Innenverteidiger, der da plötzlich vorne auftaucht. Das ist dann halt schon so der, ja so dieser Knackpunkt, dass die Spieler irgendwie quasi jede Position irgendwann einnehmen können und sich dann auch wissen durchzusetzen und auch wissen, wo steht mein Mitspieler und wie bringe ich den Ball jetzt rein und ich glaube, das hat Walter ihnen dann in der Halbzeit nochmal so richtig eingetrichtert, das müsst ihr jetzt durchziehen.
Ja, da würde man tatsächlich ganz gerne wissen, was er gesagt hat. Ganz entspannt dagegen, was ja irgendwie bei dir Sina, in Bremen, 10. Minute schon, Niklas Völkruck nach Vorlage von Marvin Dux, das war natürlich äußerst originell 1 zu 0. Und dann zu Beginn der zweiten Hälfte, ich denke vor allem da dann, 51. Minute, Marvin Dux stand seinerseits mit dem Treffer zum 2 zu 0 gegen Jan Regensburg. Lief alles etwas geregelter? War es denn für dich auch so im Erleben dieses Spiels?
Überhaupt nicht. Also gerade wenn man das Spiel gegen Kiel noch im Hinterkopf hat, wo wir 2 zu 0 geführt haben und dann noch 3 zu 2 verloren haben, war das glaube ich die ganze Zeit so, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Und Regensburg hat das Spiel ja auch nicht eingestellt. Also da war schon manchmal nach vorne was dabei, gerade auch noch nach dem 1 zu 0. Und da hat man dann schon immer so ein bisschen im Hinterkopf gehabt, okay, wir fühlen jetzt zwar 1 zu 0 und ein 1-1 reicht ja auch, aber es kann ja immer was passieren. Und dann zwei Tore fallen ja dann manchmal doch schneller als man denkt. Und deswegen, ich glaube dann, so die letzten zehn Minuten hat man dann irgendwann gedacht, okay, das sieht souverän aus, das kriegen wir jetzt noch hin und könnte klappen. Aber es war doch sehr angespannt und man hatte immer so ein bisschen Angst im Hinterkopf, aber irgendwann war dann noch so der Moment, wo man dachte, jetzt haben wir es, glaube ich. Aber es war immer noch so ein bisschen so ein Glaube ich.
Ich konnte alles, das worüber jetzt wir gerade sprechen, nur in der Konferenz verfolgen, weil ich ja nebenher noch die Schlusskonferenz vorbereiten musste und dann nachts Aufzeichnung hatte und da hat man jetzt nicht so viel aus Bremen gesehen. In den Statistiken lese ich aber, den Ball hatte zu 54 Prozent Regensburg, Regensburg hatte auch mal Schüsse, 16 zu 11 Schüsse am Ende. Sagt denn die Statistik auch was aus über das Spiel? Also war das so, dass Regensburg eher die Kontrolle hatte und vielleicht sogar auch ein bisschen mehr vom Spiel, aber dann nicht die größeren Chancen als Werder oder halt auch einfach keinen Füllkrug und Ducksch, das hilft halt auch einfach sehr, wenn man zwei solche Stürme hat, können wir bei Darmstadt gleich auch nochmal drüber reden. Also wie hat Regensburg mitgehalten in der Partie?
Also ich hab's natürlich nur aus der Kurve gesehen und da ist der Blick meiner Meinung nach immer ein bisschen verzerrt, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, dass Werder das eigentlich komplett im Griff hat. Man hat Regensburg spielen lassen und leider auch ab und zu mal zu viel zu Chancen kommen lassen oder zu Torabschlüssen, da war aber nie was dabei, wo man wirklich dachte, oh das war jetzt richtig, richtig knapp. Also ich kann mich an eine Rettungstat von Pavlenka tatsächlich erinnern, aber ansonsten hatte man eigentlich so die meiste Zeit das Gefühl, Werder regelt. Und klar, also wie gesagt, Regensburg hat gut mitgespielt, aber man hatte nie das Gefühl, dass wir nicht überlegen sind, so doof das auch klingt, aber es hat schon alles funktioniert, wie Ole Werner sich das glaube ich vorgestellt hat. Und so klar, wenn du gegen einen anderen Gegner spielst als Regensburg, für die ist dann wahrscheinlich auch einfach, also es ging ja für sie nichts mehr, aber wenn du dann eben gegen jemanden spielst, der motivierter ist, warum auch immer, oder eben noch irgendwelche eigenen Chancen verteidigen oder erreichen muss, dann wäre das glaube ich anders ausgegangen. Aber so trügt die Statistik glaube ich ein bisschen. Aber auch das ist der Blick aus der Kurve und aus der Aufstiegsbrille.
Ja gut, dass wir jetzt hier keine nüchterne Analyse betreiben. Das muss auch wirklich am Tag nach so einem Saisonfinale nicht sein. Jetzt habe ich Matthias Föhlkrug und Dux angesprochen, das sind definitiv zwei der Garanten für den Bremer Erfolg. Bei Darmstadt haben wir da eine ganz ähnliche Situation, wo wir auch zwei sehr erfolgreiche Spitzen haben mit Tietz und mit Pfeiffer. Wenn du jetzt mal auf dieses Spiel guckst, da hat ja auch Pfeiffer gleich wieder doppelt getroffen, aber auch dann ein bisschen im größeren Rahmen auf dieses Saison. Welche Rolle haben die beiden gespielt? Ist es wirklich so, wie ich es jetzt gerade versuche zu frameen, dass mit den beiden ein bisschen der Erfolg von Darmstadt zusammenhängt in dieser Saison?
Ja, natürlich sind diejenigen, die die Tore schießen, diejenigen, die am meisten auffallen. Ich denke, wir können da im Laufe der Sendung ein bisschen näher noch auf Darmstadt eingehen. Sie war natürlich ein wichtiger Faktor. Wenn wir uns erinnern, wir haben vor der Saison Serra Dursun abgegeben, letztes Jahr 27 Tore. Die haben sie jetzt unter sich aufgeteilt, schlussendlich 32 Tore. Aber sie hatten davon in den ersten 16 Spieltagen, glaube ich, zusammen schon 24. Das heißt, sie haben dann in der Rückrunde nicht mehr so performt, zumindest auf dem Scoresheet, wie in der Hinrunde. Und da war schon auch gerade Luca Pfeiffer deutlich am Durchhängen, musste dann auch mal raus. Und von der Bank kommen, dafür sprang dann Aaron Seidel in die Bresche, der fünf wichtigere Tore geschossen hat in der Rückrunde, der dann aber leider auch in Endspurt die letzten fünf Spiele nicht mehr mitwirken konnte. Also Tietz und Luca Pfeiffer waren sicherlich Faktoren, die die Saison so haben gestalten lassen, wie sie sich gestalten ließ. Und sie sind auch jetzt nicht nur Stürmer, die vorne stehen und warten, bis irgendwann mal der Ball auf sie fällt und dann ist er drin. Also sie haben auch ein großes Laufpensum. Tietz ist eher so derjenige, der auch robuster ist und schon auch dem Ball gut behaupten kann, Luca Pfeiffer ist eher trotz seiner Größe um ihn herumspielender Stürmer, der auch gerne über den Flügel ankommt. Also wirkt etwas unorthodox manchmal, aber doch sehr ballgewandt. Und sie waren jetzt in dem Maße dann nicht zu erwarten, dass sie so einschlagen, weil beide hatten jetzt nicht die größte Zwo-Liga-Erfahrung. Ich glaube Luca Pfeiffer noch gar keine. Und insofern war das dann schon überraschend, aber sehr schnell funktionierend, dass die beiden so performen, wie sie performten. Und das ist gut auch für die nächste Saison zu wissen. Gleichwohl ist Luca Pfeiffer nur ausgeliehen von Metierland. Mal gucken, ob da vielleicht noch eine weitere Laie möglich ist. Wäre wünschenswert, weil ich glaube, da haben sich zwei gesucht und gefunden. Und auch schön, dass Luca Pfeiffer jetzt einfach wieder in die Spur kam, gegen Ende der Saison.
Ja, das ist sehr gut nachzuvollziehen. Und während wir bei Werder und Darmstadt ein Zwei-Stürmer-Modell haben, würde ich behaupten, beim HSV ist es ein Einstürmer-Modell mit Robert Glatze, der 22 Tore gemacht hat, damit in der Torjägerliste Rang 2, hinter dem alle überragenden Simon Terodde. Tanja, für uns mal noch so durch das Ende dieses Spiel hindurch. Der HSV kann dann durch Sebastian Schoenlau das Spiel drehen, das haben wir vorhin schon kurz angesprochen, dann auch noch auf 3 zu 1 erhöhen. Aber der HSV wäre nicht der HSV, wenn's nicht hinten raus knapp geworden wäre. Lukas Fröde kann relativ unbedrängt, wie ich finde, in der Nachspielzeit treffen und Rosso kommt noch mal auf 2 zu 3 ran. Das Klischee sagt, der HSV vergeigt viele Dinge. Und der HSV ist eben, ja, einfach gesprochen eine Drama-Queen. Stimmt denn dieses Klischee überhaupt, wenn man auf dieses Spiel blickt?
Ich fand eigentlich, dass sie dann, es war ja der Anschlusstreffer von Rostock, das war ja eigentlich schon in der Nachspielzeit, das gab dann noch irgendwie zwei Minuten, waren noch auf der Uhr und das haben sie dann aber auch, hat der HSV dann auch wirklich souverän runtergespielt. Also vergangene Saison oder vor allem die Saison davor noch, wäre das noch böse in die Hose gegangen, ganz klar. Weil sie sich dann immer sehr, haben von einer Hektik anstecken lassen, aber jetzt, diese Saison ist es tatsächlich so, dass sie viel ruhiger geworden sind, auch defensiv extrem stabil, weil wir haben, ich weiß nicht wie, aber aus irgendeinem Grunde haben wir die beste Abwehr der zweiten Liga.
Und das hat ja letztlich jetzt auch die Relegation bedeutet, das Torverhältnis hat zwischen Darmstadt und HSV entschieden.
Ja, und also insofern war mir da gar nicht mehr so bange, dass da jetzt irgendwie noch der Ausgleich fallen könnte oder so. Das haben sie dann einfach locker runtergespielt. Eckfahne gesucht, also auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite. Und dann machen sie das.
Aber kannst du erklären, woher das kommt? Denn letztlich vereinfacht gesagt, also es ist jetzt auch simplifiziert, das ist mir schon klar, aber war das ja quasi das Element, was in den letzten Jahren immer für das Scheitern gesorgt hat, dass man eben nicht die Ruhe hatte und dass man auch nicht die Widerstandsfähigkeit hatte, nach Rückschlägen zurückzukommen? Beides haben wir jetzt in dieser Partie gesehen. Also sowohl das Zurückkommen als auch hinten raus, die Ruhe, so sehr das möglich ist, in so einer aufgeladenen Stimmung, dieses Spiel dann auch einfach zu ziehen, wie man heutzutage sagt, und diesen Dreier mitzunehmen. Welche Gründe gibt es dafür?
Ich könnte jetzt sehr einfach sagen, der Grund heißt Tim Walter. Also das, was die Spieler die ganze Zeit erzählen, dass der einfach so viel Selbstvertrauen in diese Mannschaft rein pumpt, dass sie gar nicht anders können, als dann einfach weiter zu rennen und versuchen, ihr Spiel durchzuziehen. Und genau das machen sie dann auch. Sie konzentrieren sich auf ihre Stärken und alles andere lassen wir mal beiseite und machen einfach. Also der Spruch dieser Saison war eigentlich immer, wir müssen bei uns bleiben und genau das haben sie auch getan, ganz nadenlos. Sie haben nur auf sich geguckt, kennen oder haben im Laufe der Saison den Walter Ball, den sogenannten immer besser kennengelernt und immer mehr verinnerlicht und das dann auch irgendwann auf den Platz gebracht. Und zwar mit einer Souveränität, dass sie sich dachten, ja wir kriegen unser Spiel durch, dann kann hier kann uns nichts passieren.
Da ist schon spannend, welche Rolle Trainer in diesem Aufstiegsrennen gespielt haben. Ich meine, Ole, Werner und Markus Anfang, das ist ja nochmal eine ganz eigene Geschichte bei Werder. Sicherlich auch Lieber Knech bei Darmstadt und bei Schalke haben wir auch eine Trainergeschichte, aber irgendwie anders. Aber das haben wir im letzten Schalke-Fokus schon mal ausführlicher besprochen, hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir werden jetzt mal versuchen, das alles zusammenzufassen, Matthias. Also Darmstadt, Punkt gleich auf Rang 4, hat damit die Relegation verpasst. Du hast ja deine persönliche Gefühlslage schon vorhin erklärt, dass du da relativ mit wenig Erwartung in diesen letzten Spieltag gegangen bist. Was bedeutet das denn jetzt für den Verein, dass man diese Chance auf den Aufstieg letztlich so knapp verpasst hat?
Ja, Sicherheit für zumindest mal ein paar Mehreinnahmen, als man es jetzt in der 2. Liga hat. Also wir sind ja derzeit dabei, unser Stadion nach dem Umbau zu verenden. Die neue Haupttribüne wird dann auch im Laufe der Hinrunde sicherlich zu beziehen sein. Da hätte so ein kleiner Geldregen von den TV-Einnahmen in der Bundesliga sicherlich gut getan. Und das war ja auch wirklich eine sehr starke Leistung. Also ich habe mir mal angeguckt, wie denn so die letzten Viertplatzierten in den vorangegangenen Spielzeiten abgeschnitten hatten. Da wären wir in drei der letzten vier Spielzeiten sogar zweiter gewesen mit der Puntausbeute in Verbindung mit dem guten Torverhältnis. Und ich glaube, in den letzten 13 Jahren gab es nur drei oder zwei Viertplatzierte, die besser waren. Also das ist schon auch ein Ausmaß dessen, dass die Lilen es lange verstanden haben, den großen Namen Paroli zu bieten. Und das ist für die Darmstädter immer noch ein sehr hoch anzurechnender Benefit, also eine sehr große Leistungsfähigkeit, die sie in der Saison gezeigt haben. Und leider ist es jetzt so, dass wir 60 Punkte haben plus 25 vom Torverhältnis. Hätten wir gegen HSV damals nicht 5-0 verloren, sondern nur 1-0 wären wir jetzt dritter und nicht vierter. So einspielen kann in der Hinsicht auch ein bisschen was wett machen, aber da haben wir, glaube ich, dem HSV den Gefallen getan, nicht schnell genug auf den Spielverlauf zu reagieren und wir wollten mitspielen und dann ging es dahin. Und wir haben leider auch in der Rückrunde die direkten Duellen verloren. Gegen Schalke hatten wir zu Hause 5-2 verloren, da hatten wir aber vor dem 1-0-Treffer für uns schon zwei große Chancen. Da hätte es vielleicht, wer weiß, auch so wie gestern gegen Paderborn laufen können, weil das war schon so ein Muster diese Saison, dass die Lilen versuchen, von Anfang an gleich Druck aufzubauen, schnelles Tor zu machen. Und dann mündet es auch in sieben Spielen, die man mit mehr als mit drei Toren oder mit mehr gewonnen hat. Also Darmstadt war da schon im Offensivspiel nicht zu verachten und hat dann vielleicht in puncto Ballbesitz nicht die höchsten Werte. Aber wenn man führt, dann muss man einfach auch nicht so viel fürs Spiel machen. Jetzt der Contra Hand. Und um nochmal auf deine Ausgangsfrage einzugehen, also was macht der vierte Platz mit einen? Ich finde, leider gibt es keinen Bonus für die nächste Saison, weil das wäre natürlich wirklich super, wenn man mit der Punktausbeute auch ein bisschen was in die neue Saison mit rüberretten könnte. Aber es gibt eben keinen Bonus. Man beginnt wieder bei Null und insofern ist es dann leider ein gutes Gefühl, vielleicht irgendwann mal für die Spieler, aber doch irgendwie Null und nichtig. Das ist das, was so ein großer Wermutstropfen ist anbetracht der aktuellen Situation. Und wenn ich mir was für die Mannschaft wünschen würde, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das an den anderen Standorten mitgekriegt habt, aber nach Schlusspfiff war das Bölle wirklich am Brodeln. Also es war wahrscheinlich doch bei vielen so wie bei mir. Man hat erkannt, die Saison war außergewöhnlich super. Die Mannschaft hat begeistert und gespielt, 71 Tore geschossen. Da ging was. Darmstadt war phasenweise Spektakel und das haben die Fans so was von honoriert. Also ich glaube, ein Viertplatzierter in der Ausgangssituation wurde selten so abgefeiert. Und am liebsten sollten sie das, was sich nach Spielschluss da am Bölle ereignet hat, konservieren und vor dem Auftakt der nächsten Saison wieder rauslassen und aufsaugen, weil das Grundgerüst und die allermeisten bleiben einfach an Bord. Und damit ist jetzt zumindest schon mal eine Basis da, die Konstanzverlässlichkeit und vielleicht dann auch wieder ein bisschen Erfolg garantiert.
Ja, spannender Faktor, nicht nur dieses 0 zu 5 gegen den HSV, da stand es übrigens schon nach 13 Minuten 0 zu 3, also du weißt es natürlich, aber das heißt, das auf 0 zu 1 zu halten war schwierig.
Ja, weil sie dann einfach auch ähnlich wie in Düsseldorf nicht so recht wussten, was hier gerade falsch läuft. Und dann, also Darmstadt ist einfach nicht mehr dieser hohen weit Fußball klar, packen sie den auch aus, aber es ist nicht das Mittel der Wahl, das erste. Und sie wollten dann glaube ich zu sehr mitspielen und das geht nicht gut. Und in Düsseldorf waren sie einfach neben sich und haben erst nach der Halbzeit dann die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen oder in der Halbzeit und das hat mich in Düsseldorf dann auch wiederum positiv gestimmt, dass sie in der ersten Halbzeit kein Land gesehen haben und dann umstellen auf 3 auf 5er Kette, drei Spielerwechsel vornehmen und plötzlich läuft das Spiel in die völlig richtigen Bahnen und da hätte auch ein Unschieden bei rumkommen können, was uns dann auch weitergeholfen hätte. Ging dann nicht auf, aber das zeigt mir auch, dass der Trainer im Stande ist, das Spiel richtig zu lesen, dann auch die richtigen Maßgaben mit auf den Weg zu geben und die Mannschaft dann auch das Richtige macht. Also insofern lässt es für die nächste Saison hoffen.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir jetzt am letzten Spieltag gesehen, welche Kraft dieses Stadion, wenn es voll sein darf, entfalten kann. Das haben wir Sina auch in Bremen gesehen. Die Stimmung war ja fantastisch schon vor dem Spiel. Das ist immer so eine Mixtur aus. Man freut sich über die Begeisterung. Gleichzeitig denkt man sich, ja ja, hoffentlich ist das jetzt nicht das, was die Mannschaft völlig drüber aus dem Konzept schießt. Andererseits hat man das bei Werder jetzt ja schon häufiger gesehen, auch schon im Abstiegskampf aus der ersten Liga, dass dann doch die Fans da eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Auch wenn man jetzt in der Heimtabelle auf Platz 6 liegt. Auswärts war man noch ein bisschen erfolgreich, da ist aber der Unterschied drei Punkte. Also das ist alles sehr, sehr eng. Welche Rolle hat denn deiner Meinung nach das Stadion und die Fans gespielt, um diesen Schwung, den Ole Werner ja noch so ein bisschen in Abwesenheit von Teilen der Fans aufgebaut hat mit Ergebnissen, den dann auch in der Rückrunde durch die restlichen Spiele zu tragen?
Also ich hoffe mal und das sagen ja auch viele Spieler und ich glaube Ole Werner hat das auch gesagt, dass es einfach die Fans einfach so mit das Wichtigste sind und gerade so Spieler wie Leonardo Bittencourt kommen dann zwischendurch mal auch in Richtung Kurve oder bei einer Ecke und heben dann noch mal die Arme und sagen, hey, komm, mach nochmal noch mehr Stimmung und deswegen denke ich, dass das –also ich hoffe natürlich als jemand, der da steht und der da sich die Seele aus dem Leid schreibt, schreit, dass es einen Unterschied macht und ich glaube aber, dass es in manchen Momenten auch zusätzlich Druck erzeugen kann, aber gestern hat es ja super funktioniert. Ich meine, wir sind um 11.30 Uhr, 12 Uhr am Marktplatz gestartet und zum Stadion gelaufen und da waren angeblich 12.000 Leute dabei, die mit Sicherheit auch nicht alle ein Ticket fürs Stadion hatten und diese Stimmung hat sich dann auch im Stadion weiter verfestigt und es waren wirklich alle super motiviert und haben sich gefreut, weil natürlich auch nur noch ein Punkt gefehlt hat. Also es war nicht so dieser riesige Druck, okay, wir müssen jetzt auf jeden Fall gewinnen, sondern man wusste, okay, Unentschieden reicht auch und ich glaube, das hat natürlich auch so ein bisschen was dazu getragen, aber gestern die Stimmung, das war schon einzigartig und natürlich auch dann am Ende mit Platzsturm und da haben Leute das eine Tor kaputt gemacht und mitgenommen.
Das ist irgendwie der Trend aktuell.
Ja, also ich komme ja aus Düsseldorf und war damals beim Relegationsspiel von Fortuna gegen die Hertha, als die Leute zu früh auf den Platz gelaufen sind und es da diesen Skandal gab mit, die Hertha-Spieler hätten Todesangst gehabt und also ich habe schon mal einen Platzsturm miterlebt, der halt ein bisschen nach hinten losgegangen ist und deswegen bin ich da so ein bisschen vorsichtig, also da gibt es eine Untersuchung, das kostet hier glaube ich auch Geld wegen Sicherheitsperspektiven und da sind Banden umgefallen, da wurden Dinge kaputt gemacht und mitgenommen.
20 Verletzte gab es laut Polizeiangaben, das kommt auch noch mit dazu.
Ja genau, also man weiß ja jetzt nicht, was die haben, also die Sonne hat geknallt, also vielleicht ist auch ein Sonnenstich dabei, weiß man nicht, aber man muss halt immer aufpassen und das wurde auch ständig durchgesagt, so achtet auf eure Mitmenschen, es gibt schon Verletzte und deswegen aber die Emotionen dann so frei zu lassen und auf den Platz zu rennen, das ist auch irgendwie was eigenes, also ich habe mich zurückgehalten und habe mich dann irgendwie eine halbe Stunde später einmal auf den Rasen gesetzt und ein Foto gemacht und das hat mir dann persönlich gereicht, also ich musste nicht so sofort da hin rennen, aber wenn die Leute das unbedingt machen wollen, auch auf Schalke, ich habe noch kein Foto von jemandem gesehen, der sich die Hose runtergezogen hat, das gefällt mir schon mal gut. Genau, auf Schalke war es ja anders und das hat mich glaube ich auch nachträglich verstört. Das gab es in Bremen glaube ich noch nicht und ja, also es ist natürlich wirklich nach so einer Saison mit Auf und Abs und dann hast du es geschafft und man hat natürlich immer das Gefühl, nein wir gehören in die erste Liga und dann tut es natürlich auch irgendwie gut, wenn man dann einmal irgendwie das alles rauslassen kann.
Das kann ja sowieso jeder nachvollziehen, genauso wie die Feiern danach in der Stadt. Was ich dagegen bemerkenswert fand, war, was ich von Ömer Toprak gelesen habe, der auch nach dem Spiel erstmal für sich sein wollte und der ein eher nachdenkliches Interview gegeben hat, wie ich fand. Also ich habe es jetzt nur in online gelesen auf kicker.de, ich habe nicht die Aussagen selber aus seinem Mund gehört, aber er hat gesagt, dass er sich richtig geschämt hat dafür, dass man abgestiegen sei im Jahr zuvor und er hat auch sehr offen angesprochen, dass man in diesem Jahr so golden jetzt der Abschluss dieser Saison war. Es war nicht alles gold, was geglänzt hat bei Werder und man habe zwischendurch auch richtig schlecht gespielt. Ich glaube, er hat sogar gesagt, scheiße und peinlich war, glaube ich, seine Formulierung. Ich fand das bemerkenswert, weil sowas liest man sehr selten, vor allem in solchen Momenten. Also da muss man ja schon wirklich eine ganz eigene Persönlichkeitsstruktur haben, selbst in diesem Moment der größten Euphorie noch diese Reflektion an den Tag zu legen. Glaubst du, das steht stellvertretend für mehr als nur Ömer Toprak? Wie wertest du seine Aussagen? Verrät uns das vielleicht auch ein bisschen was über die Gesamtsituation von Werder? Jetzt mal jenseits davon, dass man es tatsächlich geschafft hat, jetzt wieder zurückzukehren in die 1. Liga. Aber der Moment ist ja Teil einer größeren Geschichte, die jetzt mehrere Jahre Abstiegskampf in der 1. Liga waren. Jetzt der Wiederaufstieg und es wird ja dann auch weitergehen.
Ich glaube, es ist auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass man solche Personen in einer Mannschaft hat. Also ich denke, dass unsere Mannschaft auch davon lebt, dass da so viele verschiedene Charaktere vorhanden sind, die sich aber ergänzen und gut verstehen. Also man hat wirklich gemerkt, aber auch schon zu Beginn der Saison, als dann die ganzen Transfers dann irgendwann mal abgeschlossen waren, dass da alle gefühlt gut miteinander können und sich gut verstehen. Und da aber auch wirklich dieses Klassengefüge, nenne ich das mal aus der Lehrerinnenperspektive, dass da alles passt. Da gibt es keine Reibungen, da mögen sich irgendwie alle. Und natürlich gibt es dann auch die Grüppchen. Aber ich habe das auch gelesen und dachte erst mal so, uff, freu dich doch erst mal. Aber auf der anderen Seite tut es natürlich auch gut, das zu hören. Nicht schwamm drüber, komm, wir sind abgestiegen, aber jetzt sind wir wieder da. Sondern dass es sich da wirklich geschämt hat. Manchmal weiß man ja einfach nicht, wie sehr die Spieler mit dem Verein verbunden sind. Und ob das jetzt wirklich stimmt, was er gesagt wird. Und das fand ich dann wirklich beeindruckend, dass er das dann auch einfach direkt nach dem Spiel dann auch so zu Journalistinnen gesagt hat und dazu steht. Und das fand ich sehr beeindruckend. Und du hast natürlich die anderen, die dann da erstmal den Trainer bei der Pressekonferenz mit Bier überschütten. Und das ist aber genauso wichtig, glaube ich. Und deswegen, dass er da wirklich so dran zu knabbern hatte, dass er mit Werder abgestiegen ist, das finde ich eigentlich wirklich beeindruckend. Und da hat mich erstmal in dem Moment so denken lassen, oh, Ömer, bitte bleib, geh nicht weg. Und vor dem Spiel hat Werder auch ein Videozusammenschnitt eingespielt und auf Social Media veröffentlicht mit Legenden, anführungsstrichen ehemalige Spieler, die dann eben Grußbotschaften geschickt haben und gesagt haben, komm, wir steigen auf. Und das war auch wirklich so ein Moment, wo man sich gedacht hat, oh Gott, wie schön ist das, das jetzt zu sehen, wenn da Diego, Naldo und andere eben extra Videos schicken und sagen, kommt Werder, ihr gehört in die erste Liga, wir schaffen das. Und auch immer von wir geredet haben, das war einfach wirklich schön. Und ich glaube, das hat man ja in jedem Verein irgendwie, aber in dem Moment denkt man sich, ach Werder Bremen, wie toll bist du denn?
Ach, das ist schön zu hören, diese positiven Emotionen. Jetzt haben wir dann Tanja noch eine hier in der Runde, für die ist die Saison noch nicht vorbei. Du guckst wahrscheinlich schon mehr als zurück, nach vorne auf die Relegation gegen Hertha. Und weil ich das jetzt bei Darmstadt und Werder schon angesprochen habe, diese Stimmung im Stadion und wir das ja auch beim HSV auch schon erlebt haben in dieser Saison, auch nicht immer erfolgreich. Also gegen Freiburg im DFB-Pokal-Halbfinale hat auch die sehr gute Stimmung im Stadion nichts geholfen. Wie blickst du denn jetzt voraus auf die Relegation gegen Hertha BSC? Welche Rolle wird denn da zum Beispiel das spielen, was Tim Walter der Mannschaft eingeflößt hat, nämlich Selbstvertrauen?
Ich glaube, das wird eine große Rolle spielen. Die Mannschaft hat gestern schon gesagt, das sind quasi zwei zusätzliche Pokalspiele und Pokal können wir, also auf geht's.
Sehr gut. Elfmeterschießen, das wird geil.
Also schon mal für Montag vormerken, das wird ein bisschen länger dauern.
Sehr gut, dann kann ich es nach meiner Royal-Aufzeichnung noch fertig gucken.
Ich freue mich tatsächlich auf die Relegation. Magath in die 2. Liga schießen, das ist schon ganz schön, weil er sich in den letzten Jahren immer zum HSV zu Wort gemeldet hat, egal in welcher Situation. Jetzt plötzlich ist er ruhig und will nichts zum HSV sagen. Das ist ein bisschen Rivalität da und wir freuen uns. Wir haben diese beiden Extraspiele, die wollten wir, und dann geben wir sie halt an.
Guck mal, das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen, dass der Spieler, der den HSV zum Europapokal der Landesmeister 1 geschossen hat gegen Juventus Turin, dass der jetzt vielleicht gar nicht mehr so positiv gesehen wird, zumindest bei dir jetzt. Aber davon abgesehen von dem Emotionalen, dass du das gerne gewinnen wollen würdest, würde es wahrscheinlich auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer nicht gerade irgendwie in die Leitplanke fahren lassen, wenn sie das beim Autofahren hören, hier gerade, oder beim Fahrrad fahren. Wenn man es sportlich betrachtet, was glaubst du werden die entscheidenden Faktoren? Ich finde es schon interessant, darüber habe ich vor dem letzten Spieltag nachgedacht, dass man mit Werder und Darmstadt zwei Teams hatte, deswegen habe ich das vorhin auch noch mal thematisiert, die zwei starke Stürmer hatten, wo ich dann auch in meinen Gedanken spiele, mir dachte, naja, da müsste sich dann entweder der VfB oder eben Hertha auf zwei einstellen und gerade bei Hertha mit Viererkette ist es dann ein bisschen schwieriger. Jetzt ist aber mit dem HSV ja ein Team in der Relegation gegen Hertha, wo es eben vor allem sich dann doch sehr viel um Robert Glatzel und dann nachrückende Spieler konzentrieren wird. Was erwartest du dir für Spiele? Wird das jetzt einfach so weitergehen, wie in der zweiten Liga bei den HSV-Spielen? Oder muss der HSV vielleicht einen anderen Ansatz werden? Dann hat man im DFB-Pokal anders gespielt als in der Liga zum Beispiel?
Das ist ja eigentlich so der große Vorwurf an Tim Walther, dass er keinen Plan B hat. Also er hat sein System, das zieht er auch nahenlose durch. Das ziehen die Spieler nahenlose durch. Da fühlen sie sich wohl in dem System. Also machen sie das. Da gibt es immer mal wieder hier und da ein paar kleine Varianten, dass er mal mit einem 4-4-2 auflaufen lässt oder so. Aber im Grundsatz immer alles nach vorne und schnell nach vorne. Lücken suchen, Abschluss, Ballbesitz. Darauf läuft es hinaus. Und ich möchte auch widersprechen, dass wir keine 2 da vorne drin haben, weil sowohl Robert Latzel als auch Sonny Kittel haben 26 Scorer-Punkte diese Saison geholt.
Ja, ich wusste bei Sonny Kittel nicht, ob ich das zählen kann. Ich weiß, aber da bin ich auch nicht tief genug drin. Wie viele davon waren denn Standards von seinen neun Toren, die er gemacht hat? Weil in meinem Kopf konnte ich mich an zwei, drei erinnern. Und dann dachte ich mir, naja, sechs aus dem Spiel heraus. Deswegen habe ich diese Unterscheidung gemacht. Aber du würdest sagen, Kittel ist quasi die heimliche Nummer zwei.
Durchaus. Also schon alleine mit 17 Assists, der spielt dann einfach irgendjemanden da vorne drinnen an. Da gibt es genug, die da rumrennen. Und dann klappt das schon. Okay. Wir sind nicht nur von Glatzel abhängig. Es ist zwar super, dass er so regelmäßig trifft. Und eigentlich in der Hinrunde ja schon, wie von einigen als Chancentod bezeichnet wurde und abgeschrieben wurde. Und deswegen freut es mich sehr, dass er am Ende dann doch seine 22 Tore gemacht hat. Aber wir sind nicht nur von ihm abhängig. Da gibt es auch noch andere, die da einspringen können. Ich meine, gestern war es dann plötzlich Mikkel Kaufmann mit dem. Auch schon keiner mehr gerechnet hat, der da so ein Ding in den Winkel zimmert.
Das war, ja... Also gut, wir werden weiter beisehen, auch in der Relegation. Und du gehst da mit einem guten Gefühl rein. Wie solltest du auch anders? Das ist sehr positiv. Dann schauen wir uns, also die emotional Unbeteiligten, einfach ganz entspannt an. Du wahrscheinlich weniger entspannt am Donnerstagabend Hinspiel im Olympiastadion in Berlin und dann am Montagabend Rückspiel mit anschließendem Elfmeterschießen im HSV-Stadion. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wie es heißt. Nennen wir es einfach weiter Volkspark.
Offiziell immer noch Volkspark-Stadion.
Cool, sehr gut.
Kühle Zeit, danke. Das Einzige, was er gemacht hat.
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich. Stimmt, das ist ja jetzt auch schon 2, 3 Jahre her. Mensch, schön.
Vielleicht darf ich kurz auf die Trainer eingehen. Und zwar fand ich das vor der Saison nicht ausgemacht, dass Werder und der HSV sich da jetzt in den Top 3 tummeln, verdientermaßen dann über die Saison hinweg. Weil ich dachte mir, Saison beginnt, Tanja, du magst mich korrigieren, aber Tim Walther beim HSV, der dreimal gescheitert ist, mit drei verschiedenen Trainern, mit unterschiedlichen Spielstilen. Und jetzt setzen sie auf Tim Walther, der ja streitbar ist in seiner Ausrichtung. Und es ging aber auf. Also hätte ich so tatsächlich nicht erwartet. Und bei Bremen mit Markus Anfang, den wir ja auch in Darmstadt kennen und wissen, dass es auch mal länger dauern kann, bis ein Spielsystem greift, hätte ich es auch nicht gedacht. Und insofern war für Bremen sicherlich, was ja auch oft zitiert wird, aber der Wechsel zu Ole Werner, glaube ich, ein Geschenk des Himmels. Also auch seine Puntausbeute, ich glaube, ein Schnitt von fast 2,3 spricht für sich. Das ist schon wirklich sensationell. Und insofern waren sicherlich die beiden Trainer bei uns lieber, Knecht, als Erfolgsgarant, aber auch beim HSV und bei Werder nicht gering zu schätzen. Also die Trainer haben da schon ihren großen Anteil an dem, wie es sich jetzt zum Schluss gestaltet hat. Oder wie bewertet ihr anderen beiden das?
Also ich finde es auch insgesamt bemerkenswert, wie in dieser Zweitliga-Saison auch generell die Trainer sehr präsent waren. Also eine Mannschaft wie Regensburg, die in der Hinrunde sehr überrascht hat mit Selim Begovic, die haben plötzlich angefangen, Fußball zu spielen. Das kannte man in den Jahren davor von ihnen nicht. Das war eher so eine destruktive Mannschaft. Und jetzt versuchen sie mitzuspielen und machen da so eine Entwicklung durch. Und das ist halt auch auf den Trainer zurückzuführen. Oder halt bei den Top 4, sagen wir auch durchaus Top 5, ich meine für den Stadtteil hier nebenan. Bei denen ist ja auch durchaus der Trainer sehr präsent. Und auch da ist der Erfolg durchaus auf den Trainer zurückzuführen.
Von daher …Nürnberg würde ich da auch noch mit reinnehmen.
Oh ja, auf jeden Fall. Die haben auch am Trainer festgehalten.
Da gibt es einige, die tatsächlich so ein bisschen den Stempel aufgesucht haben. Auch Karlsruhe mit Eichner. Bleibt spannend, aber gerade auch mit Bremen. Ich weiß nicht, wie du es bewährtest, Sina, aber ich denke, der Trainerwechsel war nicht der verkehrteste.
Ich fand, der kam zu früh. Genau richtig, hat genau gepasst. Na ja, gut, einen Spieltag vorher, und wir hätten vielleicht die Radkappe da bekommen, aber man ist ja froh mit dem, was man hat. Als Rheinländerin habe ich mich natürlich erst mal gefreut. Da kommt ein Kölner, und im Endeffekt hat sich herausgestellt, ja, ne, passt nicht. Ich glaube, dass Ole Werner sowohl was das System angeht, als auch die Spielidee und von der Persönlichkeit perfekt reinpasst. Nordisch by nature. Ich glaube, was Besseres hätte, wenn es nicht passieren könnte. Und es ist ja auch bezeichnend, dass er eigentlich schon von Anfang an als Wunschkandidat ganz oben auf der Liste stand. Und damals er aber noch bei Kiel war und es nicht funktioniert hat. Und dann wirklich dieses Geschenk des Himmels, dass da irgendwie halt jemand einen Impfpass fälscht, kann ich ja auch nicht ausdenken eigentlich. Das ist dann halt einfach perfekt.
Es geht doch tatsächlich nur im Kontext mit Markus Anfang, dass man diesen Satz sagen kann. Ein Geschenk des Himmels, dass jemand einen Impfpass fälscht. Aber wir haben dich verstanden.
Ich hab mich da natürlich wirklich viel drüber aufgeregt. Auch als er dann damals vor einigen Wochen, Monaten im Sportstudio war und darüber noch mal geredet hat, da hab ich auch im Weserfunk dann noch mal ein bisschen über ihn, oder nicht über ihn, aber über diese ganze Aktion hergezogen und hab da eben eine Meinung zu. Die ist eben nicht gut, aber so die Konsequenz daraus, dass wir jetzt Ole Werner haben, dass wir aufgestiegen sind. Natürlich, er hat auch Grundlagen gelegt. Also ich glaub nicht, dass er hier alles komplett falsch gemacht hat, was das Trainerische angeht. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir es mit Markus Anfang tatsächlich geschafft haben, so eng, wie es da oben jetzt auch war.
Hätte es Darmstadt 98 mit Markus Anfang geschafft, ist die interessante Frage.
Ja, ich habe ihn durchaus als ein bisschen beratungsresistent empfunden. Also er hat seinen Stil, der ja offensiv ausgerichtet ist, durchgezogen, bis es gar nicht mehr anders ging. Und dann hat er auf Doppel-Sechs umgestellt und das Spielsystem spielen lassen, das die Mannschaft kannte. Und ab da lief es wie geschmiert, aber da musste er ja schon deutlich angezählt werden. Weil da standen wir mehr oder minder über dem Strich unten allerdings. Und man hat ihm hier jetzt nicht sonderlich viel Tränen nachgeweint, was aber vielleicht auch an der Corona- und Geisterspielsituation lag, weil wir ihn nicht wirklich haben kennenlernen können. Aber er wirkte doch auch eher so ein bisschen als jemand, der einen klaren Karriereplan hat, der irgendwann in der ersten Liga ankommen will. Ist legitim, aber wenn man ihn jetzt Lieberknecht gegenüberstellt, dann spricht Lieberknecht sehr viel mehr die Sprache der Fans und ist was fürs Herz und versteht auch, wie so ein Verein tickt. Und ich glaube, das war Markus Anfangen hier in Darmstadt nicht so gegeben.
Tanja, spricht Tim Walter auch die Herzen der HSV-Fans an? Zwischendurch wackelte ja sein Trainerstuhl durchaus in Hamburg. Haben wir auch hier im Rasenfunk schon mehrfach thematisiert. Hat sich da dann was verändert, was jenseits von Ergebnissen stattgefunden hat? Oder waren einfach dann die Ergebnisse besser und deshalb durfte er bleiben? Und jetzt ist ja sowieso alles tippitoppi. Wie würdest du das einordnen?
Also, man weiß es nicht so genau. Diese Diskussion, die in den letzten Wochen dann aufkam, von wegen auch, dass der Aufsichtsrat Tim Walter loswerden möchte. Und irgendwann das Argument durchgestochen wurde, dass ein Aufstieg mit Tim Walter ja viel zu teuer wäre. Was ich auch noch völlig weird finde, weil man dann ja viel Geld in die Mannschaft investieren müsste und das Geld hat man nicht. Das fand ich einen sehr merkwürdigen Argumentationsstrang. Ich meine, ich habe in den vergangenen Jahren mein Herz sehr an HSV-Trainer gehängt. Daniel Thun war fantastisch. Das merken jetzt die Düsseldorfer gerade. Bei Tim Walter bin ich immer noch einfach... Er ist da, sein Fußball ist sehr attraktiv. Ohne Zweifel. Die Spieler folgen ihm. Es ist eine junge Mannschaft. Man sieht tatsächlich diese viel proglamierte Entwicklung. Die sieht man tatsächlich. Und damit bin ich glücklich. Wir spielen wirklich guten Fußball. Da sind Jungs dabei. Das macht richtig Laune, die zu sehen. Und zu sehen, wie sie dann an den Aufgaben wachsen. Mehr will ich gar nicht. Da ist es mir dann auch egal, wer der Trainer ist.
Aber dann lass doch gleich bei Daniel Thun bleiben, weil der gehört ja auch zu diesen Trainergeschichten dieser Zweitligasaison mit dazu. Er übernimmt bei Fortuna Düsseldorf, gewinnt sein erstes Spiel gegen Schalke 04. Und das war der Beginn einer Serie von 12 Spielen ohne Niederlage. Erst jetzt, am allerletzten Spieltag beim FC St. Pauli, hat Thun mit Düsseldorf zum ersten Mal verloren. Nachdem du ihn ja schon mal beim HSV beobachten konntest, was zeichnet ihn als Trainer denn aus? Und gehört er für dich dann mit auch zu denjenigen, die hier quasi aufs Podest der wichtigen Trainer dieser Saison gehoben werden müssen?
Daniel Thun ist, also zum einen ist er sehr menschlich, sehr empathisch, auch sehr intelligent in seiner Art und Weise. Das macht ihn so sympathisch. Und so vom Spielerischen ist er sehr flexibel. Also er guckt viel auf den Gegner und versucht da dann, seine Mannschaft entsprechend anzupassen. Beim HSV war es dann zwischendurch einfach zu viel Anpassung, die er versucht hat und irgendjemand kam da nicht mehr hinterher. Und die Mannschaft fing an, so ein bisschen den Glauben an den Trainer zu verlieren. Und dann war es eigentlich auch schon vorbei. Aber wenn er eine Mannschaft einmal gepackt hat und die mitziehen, dann ist er ein fantastischer Trainer. Also der auch dann wirklich viel Ideen hat und für den Fußball lebt. Und jedes einzelne Detail, jede Stellschraube, irgendwie versucht, dran rumzudrehen. Und macht dann auch Spaß, ihm seinen Mannschaften zuzugucken. Also wir haben auch vergangene Saison mit ihm, haben wir viele, viele Tore geschossen. Von daher, das macht schon Spaß. Ich wäre als Düsseldorfer durchaus zufrieden und glücklich mit ihm.
Ja, also wenn man sich anguckt, in welcher Situation er übernommen hat, dann ist das definitiv so. Und wenn du nicht gerade Darmstadt 98 bis zum 33. Spieltag zu Düsseldorf fahren musst, dann macht das richtig Spaß, Tune da zu sehen. Aber in dem Spiel, Matthias, hat man ja auch gesehen, wie passgenau Düsseldorf die Schwächen von Darmstadt bespielt hat, fand ich.
Ja, ich finde auch, dass –also wir kamen ja während uns mit einem 6 zu 0 Rückenwind gegen Aue und davor auch einem Sieg auf St. Pauli. Da schien sich doch wieder viel in die richtige Richtung zu entwickeln. Und dann hatte ich den Eindruck, weil ich es ja im Stadion miterleben durfte, dass Düsseldorf, glaube ich, sehr viel besser eingestellt in das Spiel ging. Also sie wussten, wie sie die Räume suchen und finden, wie die Passkombinationen zu laufen haben, gerade auch über unsere linke Defensivseite. Das sah sehr, sehr gewollt und ausgeguckt aus. Und wir mussten erstmal uns schütteln. Also die Mannschaft war, glaube ich, auch dann doch ein bisschen überfordert mit der Situation, dass sie jetzt was verlieren konnten plötzlich, je näher das Saisonende rückte. Und Düsseldorf hatte seinerseits den Rückenwind und hat ihn eindrucksvoll ausgespielt in der ersten Halbzeit. Dennoch, in der zweiten Halbzeit hat dann sich das Blatt gewendet und das machte mich dann doch wieder ein bisschen zuversichtlich, dass hier einfach auch die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen werden und die dann auch in besseres Spiel münden und nicht nur in Schadensbegrenzung oder ähnlichem. Aber Düsseldorf ist auf jeden Fall in der Form ein Kandidat, der nächstes Saison auch oben anklopft. Wer weiß, wie es dem HSV in der Relegation geht. Und wenn es härter wird, dann werden die auch nicht in der 2. Liga es sich gemütlich einrichten wollen. Kiel hat einen guten Lauf jetzt in der Rückrunde mitgenommen. Also ich denke, da gibt es diverse Teams, die wieder in Frage kommen, ein Wörtchen im Aufstiegshampf mitzureden. So ein richtig großer Player, außerdem Relegationsverlierer, ist ja dann erstmal nicht da, der jetzt so eine gewisse Erbpacht mitbringt für die Bundesliga. Da können wir vielleicht auch abschließend nochmal drauf eingehen. Da habe ich so ein paar Gedanken zu dem Thema. Aber es wird auf jeden Fall wieder eine unterhaltsame und spannende Saison, gehe ich davon aus. Und was vielleicht auch noch dazugehört, so als Randaspekt zur Halbserie, stand ja Sandhausen sehr weit unten drin, eigentlich punktgleich mit Aue, meine ich. Und bei Aue hat es dann einfach nicht mehr gereicht. Aber auch Ingolstadt hat wie Sandhausen nach meinem Verständnis ja sehr viel personell geändert in der Winterpause. Und bei Sandhausen ist es durch die Decke gegangen. Und bei Ingolstadt ohne einen nachhaltigen Effekt. Und Alois Schwarz scheint sich da einfach wohlzufühlen in der Ecke. Ist ja hier auch nicht weit weg. Und die Neuzugänge sind jetzt keine wirklich Topstars, klar, in der 2. Liga, aber sie sind namhaft. Also die bringen schon was mit. Dario Dumic kennen wir aus der 2. Liga in Darmstadt auch. Er kam aus den Niederlanden zurück. Die Mannschaft hat sich fundamental geändert, im Gegensatz zur Hinrunde. Und hat, glaube ich, auch Top-6-Rückrunde gespielt. Also auch bemerkenswert, was die immer wieder aus ihren Möglichkeiten machen.
Ja, Alois Schwarz hätte ich auch unbedingt noch erwähnen wollen, auch weil er es geschafft hat, quasi das, was ganz selten ist im Fußball zu schaffen, nämlich eben, wie du besprochen hast, Spielstil. Also nicht nur Ergebnisse, sondern auch eben die Herangehensweise an Spiele innerhalb einer Saison zu drehen. Und das war beeindruckend bei Sandhausen. Alois Schwarz, Sandro Schwarz, Entschuldigung. Alois Schwarz natürlich. Ja, irgendwie eine Institution bei Sandhausen. Ähnlich wie Frank Schmidt, den muss man auch immer nennen, finde ich, wenn man über die Trainer der 2. Männerbundesliga spricht. Heidenheim wieder 52 Punkte, zwar damit 8 Punkte Rückstand auf den Aufstieg. Aber es ist halt immer noch Heidenheim. Und bei Heidenheim ist wie das Wetter. Heidenheim ist immer da. Und anders als das Wetter überrascht ein Heidenheim, aber seltener, aber auch im Negativen nicht. Also das ist wirklich auch faszinierend. Jetzt 14 Jahre schon im Amt, 14,5 Jahre. Absolut interessante Persönlichkeit. Und ich würde gerne, ich weiß nicht, Sina, ob du da vielleicht was drüber sagen willst. Tanja, will ich die Frage jetzt nicht stellen. Timo Schulz, denke ich, müssen wir schon auch noch kurz ansprechen. Der FC St. Pauli ist ja derjenige, der aus diesem Aufstiegsrennen rausgefallen ist, der so lange auch vorne mit auf den vordersten Plätzen stand. Es sah lange Zeit nach Aufstieg aus. Und jetzt am Ende ist ja, im Endeffekt ist es ja ein langweiliges Ergebnis, in dem Sinne, dass die Absteiger wieder aufgestiegen sind. Wenn man das vor der Saison tippt, dann gähnen alle so ein bisschen. Aber Teil dieser Geschichte, dieser vermeintlich langweiligen Geschichte, ist ja, dass St. Pauli es nicht geschafft hat, aufzusteigen. Wie würdest du denn Timo Schulz und seine Rolle in dieser Saison bewerten?
Also ich glaube, das ist der Traum, den wir mit Florian Kohfeldt hatten und der nicht funktioniert hat. Ein Trainer aus dem Verein, der da seit Jahrzehnten integriert ist, der den Verein wirklich lebt und atmet, gefühlt. Du guckst dir das an und freust dich eigentlich nur für sie. Wir sind hier in Bremen ja sowieso sehr gut mit St. Pauli. Es ist schade, ich hätte mich mega gefreut, wenn wir zusammen hochgekommen wären. Aber es wundert mich auch nicht. Es macht natürlich die Überraschung überhaupt. Die sind ja sogar Herbstmeister geworden. Ich glaube, irgendwie war allen klar, dass es am Ende nicht klappt. Ich könnte mich da gerne korrigieren, aber es war schon ein kleiner Traum. Ich glaube, seine Arbeit ist da wirklich gut und wichtig. Ich habe am Anfang viele kritische Stimmen gehört, die nicht überzeugt von der Idee waren, gerade weil man dann vielleicht auch die Geschichte mit Florian Kohfeldt kannte. Wenn es dann mal nicht läuft, dann den Schlussstrich zu ziehen, ist sehr schwierig. Wir hatten das hier ja auch, dass sich niemand getraut hat, Florian Kohfeldt zu entlassen. Aber solange es läuft, ist das, glaube ich, der Traum von allen Fans des Vereins. Und deswegen, was er da wirklich aus der Mannschaft gemacht hat, die die letzten Jahre eher versucht hat, einfach nur nicht abzusteigen, das ist beeindruckend. Ich wünsche mir, dass das hält und dass sie es vielleicht dann in den nächsten Jahren packen und auch mal wieder Erstliga-Fußball spielen. Weil ich glaube, eine erste Liga mit St. Pauli, dem HSV und Werder, mehr kann man sich ja, glaube ich, nicht wünschen. So aus Norddeutscher Sicht zumindest.
Ich glaube auch, dass bei St. Pauli das Kalenderjahr 2021 super war, sensationell. Also da war St. Pauli ja wirklich erstmal in Abstiegsnöten. Dann die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen, dann ging es durch die Decke. Aber die Rückrunde würde mich schon stutzig machen. Was ist denn da schön schiefgelaufen? Weil die hatten schon ein gewisses Polster zur Winterpause.
Sieben Punkte Vorrang 3 war man zur Winterpause. Und in der Rückrundentabelle waren 13. Also Wahnsinn.
Das ist wirklich beängstigend. Klar, Kyare, ein herausragender Spieler. Kam dann vom Afrika Cup auch nicht mehr wahrscheinlich mit der Form, die er zuvor mal hatte. Zum Schluss fielen noch Burgstaller aus, aber da war es eigentlich eh schon in den Brunnen gefallen. Die ganze Geschichte. Da müssen sie schleunigst dran arbeiten. Und auch der Millonton war ja deutlich verkrezt, dass da irgendwas durchgestochen wurde. Auch vor gewissen Spielen mit, ich glaube, Aufstiegsprämie oder sowas. Da war vieles im Magen. Wenn man auch sieht, wenn sie jetzt alles verabschiedet hatten, dann geht ja da auch ein ordentlicher Ruck durch den Kader. Ich bin auch gespannt, was das dann gibt. Und das, was du sagst, das Sina kann ich, glaube ich, auch von außen betrachtet bestätigen. Ich glaube, in Dortmund wartet man auf den nächsten Klopp und findet ihn irgendwie nicht. Und bei St. Pauli scheint das ja mit Timo Schulz genau das zu sein. Also was für die Fansäle. Ein Trainer, der den Klub in- und auswendig kennt und versteht. Und deshalb wäre es ihm und dem Klub wirklich zu wünschen, dass die wieder in die Spur kommen. Bleibt aber spannend. Ich denke, die Rückrunde muss ordentlich aufgearbeitet werden. Sonst nach dem Motto, neue Runde, neues Glück, da muss schon mehr dran geschmiedet werden als nur an den Allmächtigen oder sonst was zu hoffen.
Ja, oder auf die Heimstärke, so wie ich es getan habe. Ich habe noch in der letzten Zweitligasendung hier gesagt, dass St. Pauli mit seinen drei Heimspielen in den letzten vier Partien als beste Heimmannschaft der Liga vielleicht das entscheidende Faktor sein könnte. Und gleich das Erste geht dann 1 zu 2 verloren gegen Darmstadt. Du erinnerst dich, Matthias. Und letztlich, das war vielleicht der entscheidende Knacks danach. Also auch vorher haben nicht immer die Ergebnisse gestimmt, aber man hätte sich da einfach von der Tabellenkonstellation her noch mal eine ganz andere Ausgangslage schieben können.
Absolut, es war auch ein enges Spiel. Also da hatte Darmstadt gegen Ende des Spiels kaum noch offensiv Leute auf dem Spielfeld, nur noch Matthias Honsack und ansonsten ultradefensiv eingewechselt. Aber der Dreier musste halt her. Und insofern kann man da aus St. Pauli-Sicht sicherlich lamentieren. Das war doch eine ganz unglückliche Niederlage für die. Aber im Endeffekt war dann Darmstadt imstande, den Sieg über die Zeit zu bringen. Um mehr ging es nicht. Und danach hatten sie ja glaube ich auch so einen Last-Minute-Ausgleich gegen Lürnberg und dann war es eigentlich gegessen.
Das waren die Trainer. Also nicht alle Trainer, aber doch einige Namen, über die es wert war, ein paar Worte zu verlieren. Das sagt glaube ich auch schon einiges darüber aus, wie diese Saison verlaufen ist. Tanja, wenn wir jetzt mal so das größere Bild aufmachen. Was war das für dich für eine Zweitligasaison mit Schalke und Werder als Absteiger? Schalke mit Simon Terodde und Mike Buskens und allem anderen. Über die haben wir sehr wenig geredet, obwohl sie ja auch dieser Saison ihren Stempel aufgedrückt haben.
Da hat mich mal geschrieben, Entschuldigung Max, mit Terodde ist es eigentlich eine Art Wettbewerbsverzerrung in dieser zweiten Liga, weil die ja doch sehr ausgeglichen ist. Und immer wenn ein Team glaubte, jetzt hat sie das Momentum, dann konnte man fast davon ausgehen, am nächsten Wochenende gibt es einen Rückschlag. Und mit Simon Terodde mit 30 Toren, also das ist schon wirklich ein, gerade im Saisonendsport auch, wichtiger Faktor gewesen, nimm mal die 30 Tore weg oder mach aus 30 nur 15, dann hätte Schalke da ordentlich zu Knabbern gehabt, irgendwie im Aufstiegsrennen Schritt zu halten. Selbst wenn sie jetzt als erster Aufsteiger feststanden und die Meisterradkappe geholt haben, aber das war für mich schon ein wichtiger Faktor. Und insofern fast ein bisschen, wie ich mal als Tweet meinte, Wettbewerbsverzerrung, das mal als Einwurf an der Stelle. Aber wer ihn sich leisten kann und holen kann, klar, der hat schon ordentlich was auf dem Kasten und im Kader.
Naja, sie hatten auch das Glück, dass Thierodde auch eine wirklich gute Rückrunde noch gespielt hat. Bei uns hat er ja auch eine Wahnsinns-Hinrunde gespielt und ist dann in der Rückrunde eingebrochen, zusammen mit dem Rest der Mannschaft. Auch Thierodde ist kein Aufstiegsgarant für euch getestet.
Ja, aber vielleicht, wenn wir darüber reden, wie die Ligen spannender werden, vielleicht wäre das die Lösung. Wir machen Simon Thierodde in der zweiten Liga und Robert Lewandowski in der ersten Liga zum Wanderpokal. Und immer der Verein, der es knapp verpasst hat, der kriegt ihn in der nächsten Saison. Und dann hat man damit wieder Spannung garantiert. Das könnte es doch gewesen sein. Aber Tanja, wenn du dich in fünf Jahren zurückerinnern wirst an diese Saison, jenseits vom HSV, davon wird natürlich die Erinnerung geprägt sein, ob das jetzt klappt in der Relegation oder nicht. Aber darüber hinaus, an was wirst du dich wahrscheinlich zurückerinnern, was diese zweite Zweitligasaison angeht?
Ich glaube, dass sie insgesamt fand ich den Eindruck, dass es eine sehr emotionale Saison war. Mag an der Rückkehr der Fans auch gelegen haben, dass das so mit reinspielt, aber ich hatte irgendwie immer so das Gefühl eines Etnisterns auch dann durch den engen Aufstiegskampf und so weiter. Das ist halt das, glaube ich, was hängen bleibt. Es war einfach so viel drin und so viel Emotionen mit drin, dass es eine Gänsehautsaison letztlich war. Ich denke auch für Darmstadt, Werder, Schalke sowieso gilt das wahrscheinlich auch. Ich glaube, selbst der Stadtteil nebenan ist durchaus mitgenommen. Ja, letztlich werden sie zufrieden sein mit Platz 5. Das haben sie vor der Saison nicht unbedingt mitgerechnet.
Sina, für dich war es ja die erste Zweitligasaison, so als direkte Beteiligte. Zumindest seit ganz langem. Nee, doch müsste die erste gewesen sein. So alt kannst du nicht sein. Sorry, ich wollte jetzt gar nicht über dein Alter spekulieren. Aber wie hast du denn diese Saison erlebt? Die Frage wollte ich eigentlich stellen. Hätte ich sie doch einfach gestellt.
Also, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, es war schon irgendwie schön. Ich meine, ich habe jetzt nicht irgendwie die utopische Vorstellung, dass wir jetzt ganz oben mitspielen in der ersten Liga. Das wird vielleicht auch jetzt so unser Schicksal sein, dass wir vielleicht erstmal wieder zur Fahrschulmannschaft werden. Man weiß es ja nicht. Aber gerade so mit der Rückkehr ins Stadion. Ich habe die letzten Ausweisfahrten jetzt auch alle mitgenommen. Ich habe den Nudeltopf in Aue gegessen. Absolutes Highlight. Nicht kulinarisch, aber fürs Gefühl. Schalke war schön. Gut, das haben wir in der ersten Liga auch häufig gehabt. Aber ich war vorher auch noch nie auf St. Pauli. Das war auch echt cool. Natürlich konnte man nicht alles mitnehmen, aber auch einfach mal wieder gewinnen und dieses Gefühl. Auch von Bedeutung zu sein in der Liga und nicht irgendwo unten oder im Mittelfeld rumzudümpeln, das war schon echt ganz nett. Man muss auch ehrlich sagen, diese Saison war die zweite Liga einfach interessanter. Klar, man hat da jetzt die eigene Perspektive, aber die Bayern sind wieder Meister geworden. Abstiegskampf in der ersten Liga, okay, war jetzt echt nochmal spannend. Aber was sagt das denn darüber aus, dass das Spannendste einer Liga wirklich der Abstiegskampf ist? Ich habe die jetzt wirklich gerne mitgenommen. Das Ding ist halt immer, dass man im Hinterkopf hat, da hängen Jobs dran, da gibt es viel weniger Geld. Deswegen ist man jetzt auch einfach froh, wieder oben zu sein und dann auch wirklich sagen zu können, erst Klassik. Da gehören wir hin eigentlich. Hoffentlich wird es dann einfach die nächsten Jahre immer wieder spannender. Es war emotional extrem, gerade durch die viele Zeit ohne Stadion und ohne Fans. Ich finde, man hat gerade in den letzten Wochen wirklich extrem gemerkt, was Fußball ohne Fans eigentlich ist. Nämlich gar nichts. Ob das jetzt Frankfurt ist, ob das auch der FC ist oder Werder, HSV, das ist so ein Unterschied. Und es tat so gut, das einfach wieder ausleben zu können und wirklich wieder Fan sein zu können und nicht nur von zu Hause alles beobachten zu können. Das war einfach eine Achterbahn.
Ja, und wer weiß, also der letzte Aufstieg war ja 1980, 1981, damals mit dem neuen Trainer Otto Rehagel. Und der sollte ja dann doch noch eine ganz gute Karriere bei Werder machen. Vielleicht kann ja Ole Wanner da eine kleine Parallele ziehen. Wie schön ich da jetzt gerade Druck aufgebaut habe. Mir fällt es immerhin selbst noch auf. Und darüber hinaus, was wird bei dir hängen bleiben, Matthias? Für Darmstadt war es jetzt die fünfte Zweitligasaison in Folge, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Das heißt, du bist der Zweitliga-Veteran. Da musst du uns ja eigentlich erzählen. Was war denn anders in dieser Saison? Diese ganzen jungen Neuen, die da reingekommen sind und für Wirbel gesorgt haben. Haben sie dich genervt?
Ja, ich fand es zu Beginn der Saison ein bisschen nervig, weil es wird ja schon seit Jahrzehnten von der besten Saison oder besten Zweitligasaison aller Zeiten gesprochen. Dieses Jahr konnte man das Label wohl mit einiger Berechtigung aufkleben. Gleichwohl wurde dann von den üblichen Verdächtigen gesprochen. Also die drei, die jetzt vorne sind, wurden genannt. Dann musste man schon ein bisschen suchen, vielleicht noch mit Abstrichen Nürnberg oder Düsseldorf oder St. Pauli. Aber die Zweitligaklubs, die die zweite Liga ausmachen, die wurden gar nicht genannt. Also KSC oder auch wir. Und wie du sagst, wir spielen jetzt zum fünften Mal in Folge in der Zweitligada vor zwei Erstligaspielzeiten, davor der Durchmarsch. Also auch eine Zweitligaspielzeit. Wir gehören eigentlich seit acht Jahren, wenn man so will. Waren wir zweimal Zehntal der Zwo-Liga. Ansonsten immer zu den Top-25-Clubs. Aber Darmstadt taucht irgendwie gar nicht auf in der allgemeinen Erzählung. Dabei sind wir auch in der ewigen Tabelle der Zwo-Liga, mittlerweile Siebter. Also das ist schon krass so gewesen, dass wir in der heißen Phase des kommerziellen Fußballs leider abgehängt waren. Also da waren wir Dritt- und Viertligist und deshalb sind wir gerade auch bei den jungen Fans wahrscheinlich einfach nicht präsent oder irgendwie so ein Underdog. Aber ich denke, wir haben das Label Zwo-Ligist nicht zu unrecht und beweisen das Spielzeit für Spielzeit. Wenn man betrachtet, wo wir vor zehn Jahren standen, dann ist das schon vor 15 und 20 erst recht bemerkenswert. Und deshalb mache ich da so ein gewisses von der ersten Liga her kommendes –ja, oder wie soll ich sagen? Also die erste Liga dominiert durchaus viel und strahlt auf die zweite Liga ab. Und wenn große Klubs runterkommen, weil einfach auch mittlerweile sich in der ersten Liga Klubs tummeln, die da eher überraschend sind, dann wird es halt auch irgendwie eng und dann rutschen einige runter, wie jetzt vor dieser Saison. Und dann ist es plötzlich so, dass man auch erwartet, dass die hochgehen. Also was hat denn bitte schön Schalke in der zweiten Liga zu suchen? Was hat Werder in der zweiten Liga zu suchen? Die sollen bitte schön wieder hochkommen. Vor der Saison gab es auch Aussagen hier vom benachbarten hessischen Club, der auch festgestellt hat, da geht der Bundesliga aber eine gewisse Strahlkraft nach Übersee verloren. Wenn hier plötzlich Fürth spielt und Bielefeld spielt und Bochum spielt, dann muss ich sagen, herzlich willkommen. Das nennt man Wettbewerb, ja. Also man hat hier keinen Closed Shop in der ersten Liga, sonst können wir auch die Super League in die erste Liga verfrachten. Das wollen ja die Traditionsfans auch nicht. Aber dass dann in solchen Clubs wie uns oder auch vielleicht Paderborn es abgesprochen wird, oder jetzt auch Fürth-Erstliga tauglich zu sein und dadurch bitte schön nichts verloren zu haben, das hat man auch im Aufstiegskampf immer wieder so gehört. Natürlich in den sozialen Medien, die eh gerne lauter sind, als es vonnöten ist. Aber ich finde das mitunter auch gering schätzend. Und wenn man sieht, dass Darmstadt in der Saison zwar jetzt die entscheidenden Spiele Federn hat lassen, aber doch 71 Tore geschossen hat, sehr ansehnlich gespielt hat, mit einem jungen Team, entwicklungsfähig, mit einem Patrick Pfeiffer in der Innenverteidigung, der höchstwahrscheinlich zu höheren Berufen ist und uns womöglich abhanden kommt, aber hier eine enorme Entwicklung genommen hat vom HSV 2 in drei Jahren zu einem der Top-Innen-Verteidiger der Liga, dann zeigt das auch, dass hier was geht und dass hier gut gearbeitet wird und dass ein sportlicher Leiter wie Carsten Wielmann eine super Arbeit macht und das Trainerteam mit Lieberknecht und Obetay Ju erst recht. Also da findet sich was, da gibt es Nischen, da gibt es Möglichkeiten zu begeistern und das ist auch das, was die zweite Liga ausmacht, dass mal so ein Klub deutlich an die erste Liga klopft, den viele überhaupt nicht auf dem Schirm haben und die ihm deshalb so ein bisschen die Berechtigung anzuklopfen, absprechen. Aber ich finde, das ist so eine gewisse Hochnäsigkeit. Jetzt äußere ich es, weil ich mich da auch ein bisschen angegriffen fühle als Darmstadt-Fan, aber das trifft auch andere. Also wie ich sagte, Paderborn oder Fürth oder wer weiß, vielleicht auch dann wieder der KSC.
Heidenheim ja auch.
Heidenheim auch und deshalb geht mir das so ein bisschen auf den Zeiger, weil gerade auch viele Traditionsfans sagen, ja bitte schön die Traditionsklubs oben rein, aber dann haben wir halt so eine Superliga auf Bundesligaebene und was soll das? Also dieser Wettbewerbscharakter, der vielleicht in der ersten Liga nicht mehr so ausgeprägt ist, zumindest vorne, der ist halt nur in der zweiten Liga gegeben und deshalb ist das ein Appell, doch bitte die zweite Liga auch ernst zu nehmen und nicht zu sagen, hat er nichts verloren, eine Etage höher. Und das ist mir so jetzt aufgefallen, hat sich so über die Saison ein bisschen aufgebaut und fiel am Anfang auch schon auf mit der besten zweiten Liga, wo viele traditionelle Zweitliga-Klubs einfach gar nicht vorkamen in der Erzählung. Und dennoch stimme ich auch den beiden anderen zu. Also es war eine emotionale Saison, die Fans kehrten zurück, es war ein enger Fight nach vorne hin, wo immer wieder unterschiedliche Konstellationen von Spieltag zu Spieltag waren und insofern hat die zweite Liga wirklich Unterhaltungspotenzial. Also nicht durchweg, aber in sehr vielen Fällen. Und deshalb, ja, Tschüss HSV und Tschüss Werder. Aber das war Liga 2, das ist kein Durchmarsch, das ist auch nicht nur kämpfen und beißen, sondern da ist auch durchaus ein gepflegter Ball am Start.
Eigentlich will ich die Liga auch gar nicht verlassen.
So habe ich zwischendurch auch gedacht, gar keine Lust so gegen Bayern, Leipzig zu spielen. Das muss eigentlich nicht sein, Hoffenheim, nee.
Ja, aber weil man mehr gewonnen hat oder wegen anderer Aspekte der 2.
Ja klar, das gehört mit dazu, dass man einfach, man hat in der 1. Liga jahrelang wie ständig auf die Schnauze gekriegt und jetzt kommt man einfach mal oder geht mit einem positiven Gefühl ins Stadion. Das ist schon netter, aber auch insgesamt so. Es ist viel kuscheliger. Man sieht mal ein paar neue Menschen und man fährt nicht das 10. Jahr hintereinander nach Augsburg oder Mainz oder sonstiges. Also nichts gegen Augsburg oder Mainz. Beim besten Willen nicht. Die sind sehr nett. Ich bin da bei dir.
Ich kann dich total auf der Knie.
Aber dann lernt man halt Heidenheim kennen oder Sandhausen, wo du richtig herzlich empfangen wirst. Und das ist dann auch wirklich schön. Ja, und wo auch gute Arbeit gemacht wird.
Also Max, du wirst ja auch als Begleiter der 1. Liga kennen. Welche Vereine haben es denn, um mal so diese Close-Job, erste Liga aufzumachen, nochmal, wie viele Vereine haben es in den letzten zehn Jahren geschafft, sich in der ersten Liga zu etablieren? Ja, Augsburg und Berlin, oder? Also Augsburg schon von vor zehn Jahren. Die sind jetzt, glaube ich, dann zum zwölften Mal oder dreizehnten Mal dabei. Aber außer Union hat es ja keiner geschafft, sich da zu etablieren. Wenn, dann gehen viele Klubs nach der zweiten oder dritten Saison wieder runter. Oder es gibt dann so Fahrstuhlklubs wie Stuttgart oder Köln, die dann immer wieder auch oben reinstechen können. Aber es ist doch ziemlich abgeschottet. Und durch diese Relegation hat man streng genommen ja dem Zooligisten einen Aufstiegsplatz weggenommen. Weil es haben, glaube ich, seit dieser Wiedereinführung erst drei Clubs geschafft. Ganz am Anfang Nürnberg, dann, glaube ich, Düsseldorf. Sina hatte das Spiel uns in Erinnerung gerufen. Und zuletzt auch Union. Ansonsten war immer der erste Ligist, und der konnte noch so schlecht spielen. Derjenige, der sich durchgesetzt hat. Und insofern gibt es eigentlich nur noch zwei Absteiger und zwei Aufsteiger. Und das ist dann doch so eine gewisse Besitzernswahrung.
Klar. Aber ich glaube, da kommt ja auch so ein bisschen das her, was du beschrieben hast. Weil zu den, also es haben sich Augsburg und Union haben sich etabliert und Mainz in der ersten Liga. Und dann kommen ja noch zwei Teams mit dazu, die man aber aus gewissen Gründen nicht nennt, nämlich Hoffenheim und Leipzig. Aber das sind ja, wenn man das einfach ganz normal betrachtet, sind das fünf Plätze, die in der ersten Liga für andere Teams nicht da waren. Deshalb hat das andere rausgedrängt. Und ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr die Zeit habt, können wir auch noch kurz über Relegation zur dritten Liga sprechen. Wir haben jetzt leider den Abstiegskampf komplett ausgeklammert bisher in dieser Sendung. Aber gewisse Mannschaften sind verschwunden. Und ich glaube, was du gesagt hast, Matthias, da muss man eine Unterscheidung machen. Ich glaube, sportlich gesehen habe ich das zumindest jetzt nicht so wahrgenommen, dass Bielefeld, Fürth oder auch Darmstadt sportlich gesehen, das abgesprochen werden würde, dass man es nicht verdient hätte, aufzusteigen oder nicht gute Arbeit machen würde. Ich glaube, es geht dann eher um weiche Faktoren, die dann auch sehr subjektiv sind. Deswegen gibt es da quasi jede Diskussion darüber, ist sehr vom Standpunkt des Diskutierenden abhängig. Aber zum Beispiel geht es halt um so Fragen wie überregionales Interesse, wie Zuschauerschnitt. Und da gibt es dann einen Unterschied. Also wenn ich mir jetzt den Zuschauerschnitt dieser zweiten Liga angucke, Quelle ist jetzt transfermarkt.de, dann ist auf Platz 1 Schalke mit 33.000, Platz 2 Werder mit 29.000, Platz 3 HSV 23.000, Nürnberg auch 23.000, St. Pauli 18.000, Düsseldorf, Rostock, Dresden und so weiter. Und Darmstadt kommt dann, da ist jetzt natürlich auch Corona mit dabei.
Und der Stadion-Umbau in erster Linie. Also wir haben gar nicht die Auslastung.
Genau. Und ich will jetzt auch gar nicht sagen, hey, Zuschauer, Auslastung soll alleine darüber entscheiden, wie man einen Verein bewertet und auch welche Bedeutung er für eine Liga hat. Aber ich glaube, das kommt halt bei so was mit rein. Und meinem Gefühl nach leiden Vereine wie zum Beispiel Darmstadt unter dieser Erstligasituation mehr als die Vereine, die auf- und absteigen. Weil sie eben noch mehr marginalisiert werden eigentlich. Das konnte man auch mit Unionerinnen und Unionern sehr gut besprechen, die einfach so lange in der 2. Liga waren und die einfach dieses Kommen und Gehen gesehen haben. Da kommt halt von oben, fällt ein 1. FC Nürnberg runter und dann geht er wieder rauf. Und irgendwann ist Nürnberg dann aber so runtergefallen und der Platz wurde so eng in der 1. Liga, dass die nicht mehr rauf gekommen sind. Ich meine, das ist ja auch eine Geschichte. Und davon hast du zwei, drei Vereine. Und solche Mannschaften wie Kaiserslautern zum Beispiel sind noch tiefer gefallen und haben ganz andere Probleme. Dresden ja letztlich auch, Rostock gehörte auch mit dazu. Also das sind so ineinander verwobene Diskussionen, wo dann auch manchmal subjektive Dinge mit reinkommen. Deswegen macht es auch manchmal, also in manchen Foren ist es dann auch schwierig, darüber zu diskutieren. Und gleichzeitig gibt es da auch keine Lösung. Weil natürlich kann nur das Sportliche darüber entscheiden, wie der aufsteigt. Und jeder, der aufsteigt, der hat es dann auch verdient. Also egal, wie die Relegation es läuft, der HSV hätte den Aufstieg definitiv verdient. Da wird niemand sich beschweren. Und so wäre es aber bei Darmstadt auch. Aber es gibt ebenso Nebenfaktoren. Und die prägen, glaube ich, wie wir über Ligen reden. Und der Unmut, den viele über die erste Liga haben, der zeigt sich dann auch in der Glorifizierung der zweiten Liga. Denn ich finde, das gehört zur Wahrheit auch mit dazu. Ich habe viel mehr zweite Liga gesehen in diesem Jahr als sonst. Ich habe auch an einem Spieltag mal alle Spiele gesehen, weil ich mich vorbereitet habe für einen anderen Podcast. Und nur sportlich gesehen, so geil ist die zweite Liga dann auch nicht. Tut mir leid. Also ich verstehe die ganze Folklore. Und dass es spannend war und so weiter, das sehe ich schon auch. Aber sportlich gesehen, boah.
Ja, ich denke, es gibt schon Teams, die es verdienen, genannt zu werden, wenn es darum geht, einen guten Ball zu spielen. Also Nürnberg oder auch gestern Paderborn. Das 3 zu 0, finde ich, täuscht über deren Leistungsfähigkeit hinweg. Die hatten auch sehr gute Offensivaktionen und können den Ball gut laufen lassen, zirkulieren lassen, spielen sich Chancen aus, haben Tempo drin. Also natürlich ist die Masse der Spiele jetzt nicht Deluxe, keine Frage. Aber ich finde, da gibt es schon auch Mannschaften, die nicht nur Langholz auspacken, sondern die schon auch spielerische Ansätze wählen und da ihr Mittel drin sehen. Und ich hatte auch vor der Saison mal den Thorsten Lieberknecht gefragt und während der Saison auch den Co-Trainer, ob sie denn eigentlich lieber Fehler erzwingen oder Fehler vermeiden wollen. Und beide haben gesagt, lieber Fehler erzwingen. Also es zeigt, dass es ein proaktiver Ansatz in ein Spiel zu gehen und nicht abzuwarten. Wie gesagt, trifft wahrscheinlich nicht auf die Masse der Spiele und der Teams zu, aber es gibt durchaus Teams, die da zu überraschend wissen. Auch der KSC zählt punktuell dazu, St. Pauli. Aber was du gemeint hast, stimmt natürlich auch, nur die Strahlkraft der Teams ist natürlich eine ganz andere. Wenn jetzt Werder und Schalke und HSV in der 2. Liga spielen, dann schaut man halt doch eher mal hin, als wenn es jetzt nicht diese großen Teams sind. Und auch ich als 2. Liga-Club denke mir, ja cool, Braunschweig geht hoch, das ist schon mal ein zu kräftiger Verein. Dann ist auch noch Magdeburg dabei mit einer fantastischen Fanszene. Wenn jetzt dafür Wiesbaden hochkäme, fände ich es vielleicht auch weniger cool. Muss ich auch gestehen. Also die fehlende Strahlkraft von Darmstadt, die ist ein Thema, keine Frage. Und wenn halt das Stadion dann im Endausbau nur 19.000 Fans Platz bietet, dann bist du in der Zuschauerrangliste natürlich nie weit vorne. Und auch wenn das Stadion 30.000 Fassungsvermögen hätte, wäre es dann aber auch nie voll. Das muss man auch sagen, klare Sache. Dennoch glaube ich diese Konstellation, dass die erste Liga so ein Stück weit entrückt und immer weniger Zugangsmöglichkeiten bietet, ist natürlich ein Faktor. Und dass man dann, wenn große runterkommen, eher die als diejenigen, die es zu beachten gilt, erwähnt, liegt natürlich dann auch in der Natur der Dinge.
Ich glaube auch, dass insgesamt der Unterschied zwischen 1. und 2. Liga ist gewachsen, aber auch der Unterschied zwischen 2. und 3. Liga. Also wir hatten lange Zeit immer mal wieder diese Durchmärsche. Ich meine, Darmstadt hat es ja auch gemacht, dass die dann einfach von der 3. Liga durch in die 1. Liga marschiert sind. Paderborn hat das mal geschafft und so weiter und so fort. Und das gibt es halt auch nicht mehr. Also die Neulinge, die jetzt aus der 3. Liga hochkommen, die müssen haben, auch schon stärker zu kämpfen. Also die 2. Liga ist schon besser geworden an sich, auch spielerisch. Das, was Matthias auch gerade schon gesagt hat, dass viel mehr Mannschaften mittlerweile versuchen, auch in der 2. Liga Fußball zu spielen. Aber wir haben es zum Beispiel dann im Pokal gemerkt, wir waren da zum Beispiel immer so diese Millisekunde langsamer als Freiburg und deswegen hatten wir überhaupt keine Chance gegen Freiburg letztlich. Und das ist dann halt so dieser Leistungsunterschied. Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie schnell man den dann auch tatsächlich wieder gut machen kann. Also dass man halt tatsächlich Spieler hatte, die eben doch diese Millisekunde schneller sind. Das ist echt schwierig. Also ich glaube, diese Klappe wird auch eher weiter aufgehen, als dass sie sich so schnell schließen wird.
Ja und Geschwindigkeit ist wirklich, wenn ich das jetzt mal so vergleiche, ich gucke ja alle Spiele der ersten Liga und habe jetzt viele der zweiten Liga gesehen und habe auch ein paar der dritten Liga gesehen. Geschwindigkeit und Präzision im Passspiel, das sind die zwei Faktoren, an denen sich es verändert. Ansonsten, da sind also beim Passspiel auch die Unterschiede nicht mehr so krass wie früher noch. Aber tatsächlich Handlungsschnelligkeit ist das Thema. Ich habe zum Beispiel das Spiel gesehen, Lautern gegen Saarbrücken, was vom emotionalen Her und vom Spielverlauf her ein Wahnsinn war. Absoluter Wahnsinn. Aber rein sportlich gesehen waren sogar die Tore so albern. Also das war so, dass ich... Also sowas siehst du zum Beispiel in der Frauenbundesliga nicht. Da sind die technisch und handlungsschneller, da sind die viel, viel besser. Da fallen solche Tore nicht mehr. Und das hat mich so erstaunt, weil ich in die dritte Liga am seltensten gucke und da wenigstens mitbekomme. Und ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, Lautern, Zerbrücken, ihr spielt beide um den Ausstieg, super volle Hütte und ihr habt ja auch gute Spieler. Aber da fand ich auch den Unterschied so krass. Deswegen bin ich auch sehr gespannt auf die Relegation zwischen Dresden und Lautern neben allen Themen, die man da aufmachen kann. Aber mit dem Trainerwechsel jetzt auch noch zu Dirk Schuster bei Lautern, ob man diesen krassen Unterschied jetzt auch in der Relegation sehen kann. Ich meine, mich nämlich zu erinnern, dass das in der 2. und 3. Liga-Relegation schon häufiger so war, auch wenn es da auch hin und wieder mal die 3. Liga-Mannschaft geschafft hat, sich durchzusetzen. Aber dass da der Unterschied noch krasser war als zwischen 1. und 2. Liga.
Eigentlich sind die Relegationsspiele meistens ziemlich knapp, also zwischen 2.
Ja, also wenn wir uns vor zwei Jahren erinnern, müsste es gewesen sein, als Nürnberg gegen Ingolstadt mit dem letzten Angriff erst den Klassenerhalt sicher macht. Das fand ich schon ziemlich knapp und spannend. Da hatte ich jetzt nicht so den Klassenunterschied vor Augen wie jetzt bei den anderen, sprich 1. und 2. Liga. Wolfsburg war ja zweimal in Folge in der Relegation und hatte ja echt nicht gut gespielt in der Bundesliga und hat sich dennoch gegen Braunschweig beispielsweise damals durchgesetzt. Und das zweite Mal weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr. Aber das zeigt dann doch, dass vielleicht in einzelnen Situationen es reicht, ein Spiel zu entscheiden. Das, was du mit Handlungsschnelligkeit meinst, auch im Kopf allen voran. Das ist glaube ich wirklich ein Faktor, der ein 1. Liga-Team nochmal von einem 2. Liga-Team abhebt.
Ja, doch, ihr habt glaube ich recht. Ich habe da glaube ich eine schiefe Erinnerung. Also zwischen 1. und 2. Liga sieht man es sehr deutlich. Aber 2., 3. Liga. Na gut, wir werden es ja jetzt auch sehen. Dresden gegen Lautern, das ist ja auch noch.
Also es wird wirklich spannend, zwei emotionale Fans zu sehen, beide Lechzen danach in der 2. Liga zu bleiben oder hoch zu gehen. Und Jörg Schuster weiß ja, wie Relegation geht mit uns gegen Bielefeld. Die Älteren werden sich erinnern. Ich glaube schon, dass er den Kopf freikriegen kann bei den Lauternspielern, die ja jetzt wirklich die letzten drei Spiele ziemlich dahin gehen lassen. Wird spannend. Also alles andere als ein Selbstläufer für Dresden, die jetzt gestern auch noch gegen Abo verlieren. Ich glaube, da ist auch der Baumann brennend. Puh, wird hoffentlich nicht krachen und schon gar nicht auf den Rängen. Aber es wird emotional.
Ja, emotional wird es definitiv. Sina, du warst jetzt ein bisschen aus dem Vorschlag auch ein bisschen an der Aufnahmesituation. Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was du noch loswerden möchtest? Ich möchte nicht, dass du das Gefühl hast, ich hätte doch noch gerne 13 Sachen zu dieser Zweitliga-Saison gesagt.
Nee, alles gut. Also ich freue mich auf jeden Fall jetzt auch auf die Relegation und werde mir das dann gemütlich angucken und freue mich dann, wenn der HSV es tatsächlich schafft. Also ich hätte lieber den HSV, glaube ich, mit oben als Hertha. Aber ansonsten, ich bin einfach glücklich und schwebe auf meiner Glückswolke genau vor mich hin.
Gut, dann lassen wir dich auf deiner Glückswolke und wir wünschen Tanja, dass sie auf ihrer Glückswolke sitzen wird und dass es nicht zu Nerven aufreiben wird, Tanja. Die Relegation. Geht der Puls jetzt schon hoch wahrscheinlich, wenn du daran denkst?
Auch eigentlich, wir können ja nur gewinnen. Also für Berlin geht es darum, Status Quo zu erhalten. Wir können hingegen aufsteigen, also ich finde das super. Gut. Das ist viel entspannter als umgekehrt, wenn man rechts hinter ist und die Relegation muss.
Ja, die Relegation. Sie ist ein seltsames Phänomen, aber gut, inzwischen gewöhnt man sich fast schon wieder dran. Ja, warum bloß, ja stimmt. Ich habe erst reagiert und dann nachgedacht. Und dann fiel mir Karlsruhe und Fürth ein. Die hätten da nämlich eine andere Meinung zu. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich, dass ihr mit mir nicht nur auf diesen Spieltag, sondern auch ein bisschen auf die komplette Saison zurückgeblickt habt. Auch nochmal stellvertretend Dank an alle Gäste, die mit dabei waren im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Danke an Matthias Kneifl von hoch und weit, vom Kickshoe-Block. Als at Kickshoe-Block kann man dir auch auf Twitter folgen. Ich empfehle dir das sehr. Danke dir, lieber Matthias, auch dass du mir in Hinsicht auf die ewige Tabelle der 2. Männer Bundesliga die Augen geöffnet hast.
Ich ja sehr gerne und immer wieder gerne deinem Ruf zu folgen.
Ja, das wird ja dann auch der nächsten Saison im Kurzpass wieder der Fall sein. In der Schlusskonferenz dagegen werde ich hoffentlich dann Sina mal begrüßen dürfen vom Weserfunk, natürlich auch sehr herzlich empfohlen an dieser Stelle, et-SinaSophie, auf Twitter werde ich verlinken in den Show notes. Danke dir, liebe Sina, dass du trotz der stimmlichen Belastung diese Aufnahme auf dich genommen hast. Ja, sehr gerne. Und dann drücken wir Tanja Hufschmidt die Daumen vom HSV-Talk, den ich auch sehr empfehlen möchte, und natürlich friffedfschmidt77 auf Twitter. Danke dir, liebe Tanja. Ich wünsche dir dann möglichst viel Spaß bei den kommenden Spielen, dass du es als Spaß begreifen kannst. So hat es ja auch Werle von Stuttgart gesagt. Relegation kann auch Spaß machen. Vielleicht wird es der HSV beweisen.
Ja, ich danke für die Einladung.
Dann euch lieben Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Wie das geht, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Hier im Kurzpass-Feed wird hoffentlich in der nächsten Woche noch ein Rückblick auf die europäischen Top-League kommen. Und im Schlusskonferenz-Feed werdet ihr den Rasenfunk-Royal hören können ab dem 25. Mai. Der große Saisonrückblick auf die 1. Bundesliga der Männer. In diesem Sinne, habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund und hoffentlich hören wir uns dann bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Ciao!